e
good morning everyone uh welcome to the
uh special committee on covid uh
response efficacy um I'd like to open
the meeting with a pledge uh and if
representative warry could lead us that
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all I would just like to remind everyone
that this is a bipartisan committee that
is tasked with investigating and
evaluating the state's response to the
covid-19 pandemic the committee will
function in a science-based fact finding
review specifically acquiring
comprehensive accurate data and all
related information pertaining ther
to areas of particular Focus will
include the administration of federal
guidance acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire and this morning we have
the pleasure of welcoming Dr Chan uh and
Dr Chan if you'd introduce yourself and
started testing oh there we go okay uh
good morning my name is uh Benjamin Shan
I am uh the state epidemiologist at the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services uh also an infectious
disease physician and I've been working
at the state for about 10 years now
groda thank you good morning Dr Chan
good morning so in light of the
commission the committee's um
goals I'd like to know if there are
things that now looking back on the on
what we've done as as as a whole for the
state um because I really I think the
communication that one on with the
public was very
good and um what other types of the
things do you think were both positive
or areas where we could use
Improvement yeah uh thank you for that
question um
so it might be um helpful if I frame my
comments with a few sort of general or
more broad comments um about the co9
response maybe I can first start by
saying that um you know the pandemic
was a long time you know over the course
of two or three years um and during that
time the goals and the the objectives of
what we did as a state changed right so
what we were trying to do when co9 first
emerged back in the beginning of 2020
was very different from what we were
doing even six 10 months later the goals
of our work changed over time um and
partly that was because of just the
evolving nature of a pandemic and
responding to a new emerging threat or
pathogen um and partly that's because
the um understanding or our scientific
knowledge of a new pathogen changed over
time um but I think there are some sort
of common themes throughout that long um
response and um anytime there is a new
emerging infectious disease
threat uh we oftentimes start from a
standpoint
of I think what you saw happen in the
covid-19 pandemic which is more of a
goal of containment right a containment
strategy trying to prevent an infection
a pathogen from from spreading further
as opposed to what we saw later in the
pandemic which was mitigation slowing
the spread you know lessening the impact
when a new infectious pathogen emerge
emerges often times the goal is
containment and so the question is how
do we how do we do that um and a lot of
it is by identifying people that are
infected which requires testing that's
why there's so much Focus upfront during
the pandemic on testing and getting out
more tests and if we can only test more
people we could maybe contain the virus
now that ultimately proved not to be
true but we didn't know that at the time
but there's a lot of focus upfront on
testing um but then the question is well
what do we do with the test results when
somebody's positive for example um and
that gets to you know trying to make
sure people that are infected stay home
meaning they isolate that's the
technical term and people that may have
been exposed and are at risk for coming
down with an infection quarantine or you
know remove themselves from public
settings right so those are are
technical terms and actually legal terms
isolation is for people that are
infected quarantine is for people that
were exposed and might at some point
come down with infection and so that
work that we did up front um was very
very time and labor intensive trying to
test people trying to take those people
that tested positive and make sure that
they were staying home staying out of
public places isolating um trying to do
contact tracing
uh to identify people that may have been
exposed so that they could
quarantine um that
is fairly typical with any new emerging
infectious pathogen I mean empx
outbreaks for example or marberg you
know these are just more recent examples
um people with uh highly pathogenic Aven
influenza infection right any any type
of emerging infectious disease that
typically is The Upfront work that
public health in in particular does
testing to identify people that are
infected isolation quarantine that's
part of a larger containment
strategy and I'm sorry that's a long
lead in to answer your question um which
is what what can be done or what is
needed to do a lot of that upfront work
um a lot of it is uh I think comes down
to Workforce issues Workforce Capac
capacity um this is an issue both with
Healthcare Workforce so who does the
testing for example you know we don't
have public health clinics that are
established that are that routinely
operate to try and get people tested or
vaccinated or treated right we have to
rely on the existing Health Care
infrastructure to do a lot of that work
um and that proved to and continues to
prove to be a challenge um with any new
infectious disease outbreak there's
always this push to try and set up
testing centers you know if there's a
vaccine available vaccination centers
and so it comes down to a Workforce
issue to do that upfront testing
vaccination treatment but also takes a
lot of personnel to do the contact
tracing um and the data systems involved
don't talk well to one another right so
when a provider tests somebody in in
their Health Care System had that
positive test get transmitted to Public
Health so that we can act on it you know
these two you know informatic systems
don't talk to one another um and so
there's always a natural delay in that
process and so you know I think from a
broad lens a lot of the things that are
needed come down to people Workforce
both in the healthcare sector and in the
public health sector and then um modern
informatic systems that are able to be
interconnected now some of that is
National level issues and funding that's
being worked on to have interconnected
Data Systems so that Health Care Systems
can talk with Public Health Systems can
talk with Federal systems so that there
can be a more seamless timely exchange
of information um but but those were
those were issues that came up over and
over again throughout the pandemic do we
have the people um do we have uh the
data systems um you know whether it was
you know doing contact tracing and
investigating people that were infected
that were was early in the pandemic or
needing to vaccinate people later in the
pandemic you know uh having an
information an immunization information
system that worked for example um was
was a major challenge so that that was a
long-winded answer and I apologize to
your question but I think a lot of this
comes down to people and systems Data
Systems in particular that that work um
this was also highlighted I think in the
after action report that was put out a
are you referring to the report that was
put out by the homeland security yes
okay good follow up thank you so on the
um issue of People MH I think that's
more challenging than Data
Systems especially in our state although
you know it seems to be everywhere in
this and when you're talking about
people are you talking about Medical
healthc Care people or just all sorts of
levels
um well I think it depends on what the
response requires I I know that the
Health Care System um right now even
coming out of the pandemic years later
is is struggling I I mean even finding
you know Personnel to you know support
Personnel administrative Personnel not
just the healthcare providers um but
just to to give you an example of um
coming out of the covid-19 pandemic uh
there happened to be an empo outbreak um
and and I don't want to go too far you
know into the weeds but we actually had
a
vaccine uh that can prevent empx
infection but we struggled to roll it
out because we couldn't find the Health
Care Partners that were that had the
staff and the capacity um to be able to
work with us in standing up vaccine
clinics to prevent you know to vaccinate
against empo that's the Jos vaccine um
and it was and that those kind of
remain in the healthare system but but
it's also present in um the public
health system you know there was a lot
of covid-19 funding that was put out
there for hospitals for States um and
that funding had a time limit on it um
and when that funding goes away some of
the people that were hired to do
outbreak investigations for example are
going away and so that that um on just a
routine basis that impacts our ability
to be able to investigate for example an
outbreak of you know influenza or RSV or
covid-19 at at a congregate you know
setting like a long-term care facility
those those are discussions we're
actually having internally now um
because funding is going away and so
people representative
beler thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here Dr Chan much
appreciated
um I do have a number of questions I'm
sure we'll get to them throughout the
morning um I'd like to start with um as
you testified you know when a new
pandemic arises there is different goals
that are going to occur at different
points in time and that's one of the
things we're trying to identify is sort
of when did the goals sort of change so
I guess the first question is obviously
CO's new on the scene we don't have a
lot of good information right away um I
remember way back in you know January
ish maybe February of 2020 hearing
things like you know this thing has an
rot value of six or seven this thing may
have a case fatality rate of four to 5%
so a lot of lot of information was there
at the time that was kind of sketchy um
at what point did it
become apparent uh that the initial goal
of containment was no longer a
reasonable expectation yeah yeah
representative that's a great question
and um just to clarify my my exact time
frame here is going to be a little bit
off this was like four or five years ago
um but you're absolutely right uh we
were learning about this so this not
this virus did not first emerge in the
United States right it first emerged in
China um and the flow of information
from some of these other countries was
was difficult right we we didn't have
real-time situational awareness or
knowledge um and so you know what what
we what happened was we we watched it
march across the globe first in China
and there were reports coming out about
you know field hospitals having to be
set up in China because the Health Care
system was overwhelmed and then it you
know made its way over to Europe and uh
I think many of us remember the stories
of what was happening in Italy in
particular um you know overwhelmed
Health Care Systems and then when it
came to the US um you know it was
emerging in more population dense areas
like New York City where you know I I I
remember there needing there was stories
about them using Central Park to you
know as temporary burial sites because
the hospital morgs were overwhelmed
right so so that was all that that was
we were watching this happen here in New
Hampshire waiting for it to arrive um
yet with limited information because a
lot of what was happening was in other
countries and so it wasn't until the
virus arrived here that we were able to
learn better how it spreads um but even
with that limited information the
initial goal was Containment right test
people identify infection you know uh
containment you know um that our first
case was March 2nd of
2020 and we were in that mode of
containment for you know the time frame
here is on the order of weeks to a few
months and we were discussing
individual cases every evening running
what we call line lists you know talking
about um you know person a had it doing
contact tracing to identify the other
people that might have been exposed
reaching out to person a to make sure
they were isolating and then the other
close contacts so that they could you
know quarantine um and it it's a it's a
Time intensive effort to do that type of
case investigation and contact tracing
um but we were at it for weeks and
months but probably so the first case
emerged beginning of March you know
through um April May I I mean I would
say by you know the beginning of
summertime and these are rough estimates
it it was clear that you know this was
not a virus that could be
contained um and that's when we were
moving more towards mitigation or
messaging at least publicly more about
the need for mitigation so it was no
longer just about testing and
identifying infections and contact
tracing and containment um we were
moving towards what we call mitigation
um and that's that sort of Swiss Cheese
model if you will um and I I forget
exactly when we started talking about
the Swiss Cheese model might have been
you know April or or or may but we we
started talking about steps that people
can take has a comprehensive package to
slow the spread of this virus and this
was also publicly messaged at one of the
governor's press conferences we had a
PowerPoint you know little PowerPoint
slides we put up showing the goal of
mitigation was to slow the spread
decrease the peak you know decrease the
burden on the Health Care system and I
forget exactly when that was um but but
that mitigation involved steps like
physical distancing you know staying
home when you're sick you know um masks
fact in it at some point it it might
have been May when we were talking about
wearing masks a lot of that initial
messaging though was wearing masks when
people went into the Health Care System
right it was focused on protecting the
Health Care System um and you know good
hand hygiene you know avoiding large
Gatherings you know being outdoors as
being as being safer than being indoors
that that was all um I think messaging
that we were rolling out end of spring
beginning of summer yet we were still
also engaged in the in the um contact
tracing and containment strategy and so
there's overlap between the two phases
right we're doing containment well that
that phases out you know we're we're
increasing some of the the messaging
measures and and can I I'm sorry can I
add one more thing that
um and and I think we we were all
waiting for a vaccine to come come out
because that was another huge transition
point in the goals and the objectives
vaccination allowed us to um ease up on
some of those recommendations and just
as an example of that you know the
vaccine became available middle to end
of December
2020 um you know so like 8 10 months
into the
response and it was I think in January
when we came out with the recommendation
that you know people that are vac inated
who might be exposed to covid-19 do not
need to quarantine right and so that was
that was a huge step and New Hampshire
actually took that step well before the
federal government ended up taking that
step but at that time the data we had
pointed to a highly effective vaccine
the clinical trials were showing that
the vaccines were 95% effective at
preventing infection not just more
severe disease um and so we used that
initial data to change
the goals of the response to relying
more and more on the Therapeutics like
vaccination um to be able to pull back
on some of those mitigation measures so
so if I had to frame this big picture it
would be you know initial stages weeks
to two or three months like pure
containment became very clear very
quickly that wasn't possible so then we
moved to slowing the spread
mitigation and ultimately the goal was
always to rely more and more on
pharmaceutical intervention
vacc vaccines monoclonal antibodies
antiviral medications to be able to then
pull back on the the recommendations for
the mitigation measures and rely more on
protection from natural immunity from
vaccination with the availability of
Therapeutics for people that became
infected for example so I'm I'm sorry to
add that at the end I just wanted to add
that last piece oh no I appreciate it I
mean the more data we get the better we
can understand what's going on and move
forward uh in the future right so um I
do have a question on something that you
you said is you know when we're
monitoring and in the
containment section of the covid um do
we do you have numbers of the age groups
of people that were really being
affected um uh do you know what the age
groups were and how you know because you
have you know infant to five you have
teen you have you know 20s to 30s 30s to
40s do we have you know we know the
elderly was really affected but do we
have any data of how that breakdown
happened during the containment yeah
it's a it's a good question about uh
data and I I I don't I don't know those
numbers we were putting those numbers
out um on a regular basis either at the
press conferences or on the data
dashboard that ultimately was stood up
that I I think it's still the data
dashboard is still up although the dat
is paired back um and I think that the
data came from a variety of different
sources and this actually goes back to
my initial comments about the importance
of systems data systems for example that
that talk with one another um we were
getting reports of positive tests so
there was test data we were getting
reports of people hospitalized with
covid-19 so we have you know
hospitalization data there's death data
from vital that we were getting from
Vital Records review um emergency
department data so the data was coming
in from a variety of different sources
and to your question we we were breaking
down um that data by like age group for
example and I I don't remember those
numbers but those had been up on the the
data dashboard at one point I think
they've since been removed because it's
historical data it's like four four
years old now
um but but you know I would say that
there there wasn't one particular age
group that was being infected to my
recollection more than another I mean
this was a novel virus nobody had
immunity or protection from it everybody
was susceptible to getting infected and
everybody was you know regardless of the
age group was getting you know infected
now certainly there were people that
were more susceptible to severe disease
and and those are the the PE the
individuals that we typically think
about as more severe or prone to more
severe infection you know older adults
people with you know imuno comp imuno
people with compromised immune systems
people who immuno compromised people on
long-term care facilities um were were
largely impacted by you know outbreaks
so I I think the virus impacted
everybody at all age groups but
certainly there were populations that um
developed more severe
disease representative uh P off uh thank
you Madame chair and thank you for being
here and taking our
questions uh so uh about uh uh obviously
you were Central person in messaging to
the public about uh Co pandemic and
treatment so my question is like how
this decisions around treatment were
made uh uh for New Hampshire how your
office was making those decisions so for
examples Like Oxygen intubation there
was like uh over this years it changed
recommendation from putting people on
oxygen to maybe moderating
it other recommendations uh in my point
of view maybe could be questioned like
uh that people were say said to stay at
home uh if they sick and not receive
treatment until they have difficulty
breathing for example or decision to
bend certain certain cheap antiviral
treatments uh but for example V REM that
was um showed not a as good safety
comparing um to Ebola pandemic Ebola
outbreak but then it was recommended and
so like when you when you make decisions
about treatment some of those decisions
are uh message to public some of those
decisions directly implemented on
Hospital levels but could you understand
me how your office and how New Hampshire
makes uh those decisions yeah thank you
representative for the question about
treatment so let me um make a few points
up front first um our message for people
that were sick um was not to uh and I I
think I maybe I misheard you was not to
stay home until disease worsened our
message around you know illness was if
people become sick they they should call
their healthc care provider before going
in so that there a sick person isn't
like sitting in the waiting room but but
but certainly people that are sick may
need
evaluation um so you know it was never
our recommendation or messaging that
people should wait until they develop
more severe disease to go in um that
that is potentially waiting too long for
you know needed therapy um but there was
a need to try and prevent exposures in a
waiting room for example and so
Healthcare Systems had to set up
processes so that people that were
symptomatic weren't s you know sick and
sitting in a waiting room exposing other
people um so I think some of your
questions are are not um or some of your
examples are are not the purview
necessarily of Public Health so when
you're talking about um supportive care
you know how to ventilate somebody you
know how to give them
oxygen um how to you know if they're in
the ICU and on a ventilator do you lay
them on their back or do you lay them on
their stomach you know prone positioning
was a big you know top in in some of the
early days how best to you know support
somebody who's infected and has more
severe disease that's that's the Health
Care System that's the hospital deciding
based on
um uh Health Care Society you know
recommendations for example right
there's like an infectious disease
Society of America there's a soci uh
Critical Care Medicine group that puts
out you know recommendations on how best
to care for various people and the
critical care setting right so so some
some of that stuff was was really in the
purview of the healthc care system in
the hospital to to stay up to date on
and to implement where um the state
comes in is when there are
um novel pharmaceutical interventions
Therapeutics um right so monoclonal
antibodies were quickly developed and I
can't remember the exact time frame for
um being being able to give people
infected a an antibody infusion to help
prevent you know severe disease there
was also um direct antivirus medications
like REM dese which could only be
administered
intravenously um and so that uh those
were typically early on administered
just in the hospital setting um then
later on
uh uh probably 2021 sometime sorry my
time frame is not clear here you know
you had the the oral pills the antiviral
pills that came out like Pax loid in in
Mal nirav that could be used in the
outpatient setting um so a lot of the
work and the messaging that we did
around treatments was around these new
Therapeutics these new medicines to
treat infection monoclonal antibodies
and antiviral medications and that
consisted of a of a a couple things one
was simply messaging Healthcare
Providers about what these medications
were um where to find resources where to
find you know what the studies were
showing about their effectiveness or
efficacy um pointing them
to uh healthc care recommendations that
may have been published by like for
example the Infectious Disease Society
of America or the National Institutes of
Health and the NIH um was putting out uh
r guidance on how to use some of these
treatments so so a lot of this was
messaging to healthcare providers
pointing them to the resources and the
guidance that was available for how to
use these um based on the science and
the studies that were available the
other aspect um was distribution right
so these were these were medicines when
they're they're new uh they are not
available immediately through the
commercial Marketplace meaning hospitals
can't just and Healthcare Providers
can't just go out and purchase them from
you know a pharmaceutical company um
these were uh medications that were
obtained by the federal government and
then were
allocated in various ways to state
public health
jurisdictions for further Distribution
on um how best to make them
available
um that
involves so I was I'm trying to think uh
m this is where my memory is a little
bit hazy there were a lot of people
involved in that
process um and we have a a whole group
in public health uh an emergency
preparedness response and Recovery Group
um that deals and that deals with
working with the federal government
whether it's FEMA or asper or CDC or
federal HHS on um logistic Ally
coordinating distribution of these
medications but certainly there there
was a whole group focused on
um how best to make these medications
available and that included working with
going back to the original example um
working with our Healthcare System to
figure out how to deliver for example
intravenus from De to somebody that
might be might be impacted um later on
intravenous REM
became available for
outpatients not just people
hospitalized uh but the fact that it had
to be given
intravenously was is very difficult for
the Health Care system and so you don't
see that medication being used very much
in the outpatient setting um so it's a
good thing we have the oral pills like
Pax lovid and Mal the PIR um that are
that are still available for outpatient
representative Belcher then
representative thank you madam chair um
just to make sure there's no confusion
on the issue of
mitigation would I be correct in
characterizing the overriding goal of
mitigation
as uh preventing the overwhelming of
hospitals overall waiting for new
Therapeutics to come online to reduce
morbidity mortality waiting for
vaccination and were there any other um
over writing goals to mitigation yeah so
so I think what you said is correct um a
central Focus was uh preventing the
Health Care system from being
overwhelmed we saw that happen in other
countries right like Italy I mean even
in our country in New York City um
partly I think because of the population
density but that was certainly a central
goal is to um so the the way we talked
about mitigation was
to um slow the
spread so slow how quickly it's
spreading from person to person so you
know decrease that or not if you will um
lower the peak so we don't have such a
huge Spike and decrease the burden on
the Health Care System um and that in
turn would help um prevent the morbidity
and mortality that you're referring to
right the the there were issues all
throughout the pandemic of people
accessing the the health routine
healthare care services you know even to
this day we're still hearing reports
about you know how cancer incidents
might have got might have gone up
because people weren't seeking regular
screenings for you know for cancer um
people weren't going into the hospital
for you know cardiac issues right and so
there are Downstream consequences of you
know strain on the Health Care system
which impacts other aspects
non-infectious disease aspects of
people's
Health represent mcarter
thank you madam chair thanks for coming
this morning um can you try uh to give
us a picture of the
rationale um vaccinating young children
can you can you walk me through what the
uh what that looks like on your
professional level in your department of
making recommendations to continue to
vaccinate children against covid where
I've perhaps I'm wrong someone can
correct me I've been unable to obtain
any study that shows that there's been
some data to demonstrate the efficacy of
vaccinating young children can you can
you walk us through how your department
comes to that recommendation still to
this day yeah so um first off vaccine
approval and
recommendations uh at a federal level
happens through a process by which it's
reviewed by the FDA for safety and
efficacy and then it for this is for
like regulatory approval or
authorization and then it goes to a
group The advisory committee on
immunization practices or acip which is
an advisory committee that puts out um
healthc care provider recommendations so
how to use these um vaccines in a um
safe and scientifically responsible way
uh this is a group of medical
professionals that come together to you
know which includes Pediatric infectious
disease experts for example and there's
a whole I mean you can Google acip and
see all the the representation that
weighs in on you know medical guidance
um and so they go through a process of
reviewing the science that's out there
around both the safety and the
effectiveness of vaccines and they have
a whole evidence to recommendation
framework what they call the ETR um
where they go through questions about
safety and efficacy and um there's a
whole standardized process for reviewing
vaccination data um and how to frame
recommendations based on the science
that's available um so the covid-19
vaccines went through this process um we
were tuning in also to these meetings
and so also we're so we don't we didn't
have a seat at the table per se but the
the the meetings are publicly available
for anybody to to view and you know the
the PowerPoint slides the data for
example that's presented is all publicly
available for people to review um and so
we were you know not only ourselves
reviewing the scientific studies that
were coming out about the safety and
efficacy of vaccines we were also tuning
into these AIP meetings um to um listen
to the deliberation and the discussion
uh from these National medical experts
around vaccine safety and vaccine
efficacy which is which ultimately is
what influenced vaccine
recommendations um just to be clear
sometimes the FDA authorizes or approves
a vaccine for one indication but the
medical group that makes the
recommendations acip takes a different
tact based on you know what they're
seeing in the data um I will also say
that you know we New Hampshire um
Department of Health and Human Services
put out our own science memo science
brief around vaccination particularly in
in children highlighting the science and
the data uh that was 20 that was uh fall
of
2022 um we made that available to the
legislature I think this actually came
up in
discussions with uh I'm going to look
back here was it
Finance it was finance and so we made
that um document available to uh the the
legislators in um the finance group um
but that is
somewhere still available on the website
so so we should highlight some of the
the questions and the concerns you have
about the studies and the science and
the rationale behind it um I just want
to say that I have here it says the FDA
authorizes the covid-19 vaccine for ages
uh 5 to 11 on October 29th
2021 and for ages 6 months to 5 years on
June 18th of
2022 uh just uh so everyone knows what
the dates were
where the FDA uh did that um
representative
weary thank you chair and thank you Dr
Chan for taking my question
um is it it's a little soft a little
soft sorry
um so how did the emergency youth
authorization of the vaccines play into
the decisionmaking so obviously they're
under a normal
release process from the FDA as you
described they would have these things
um different events and the acip as
well but in this circumstance
for um the fizer and some of the other
companies there was an emergency youth
authorization in place how did that
affect uh the decision making and what
sort of data were you looking at to you
know um because this the eua doesn't
have the typical Effectiveness and and
safety data that you would normally
encounter in the approve approval of
such vaccines so how did the department
analyze that yeah uh thanks for that
question about the emergency use
authorization process so so disclaimer
here I'm not an expert on you know fda's
you know regulatory processes or precise
is between their authorization and their
full approval or lure what what I can
say is that
um authorization is my understanding is
a mechanism to um take data that's
available and and make in this case
vaccines um more quickly available by
cutting red tape that's that was that's
that's typically the way we've talked
about authorization the the science the
studies that were that were required by
the FDA to get authorization are the
same types of pharmaceutical clinical
trials that are required for full
licensure or full approval right we're
still talking phase three clinical
trials with tens of thousands of people
the the issue was that
um the issue I think there were a couple
differences again to my limited
understanding one is the amount of
paperwork required a pharmaceutical
company to submit and the type of review
that the FDA does and I'm not an expert
exp ERT on that the other difference um
was the long-term followup right so
these were new vaccines um that had
phase three you know large randomized
Placebo control double blinded clinical
trials associated with it um showing you
know that there were no that at a at a
you know out of tens of thousands of
people there didn't appear to be safety
concerns and the vaccine efficacy up
front it was you know were showing 9 5%
efficacy at preventing infection as I
referenced earlier but what wasn't
available were were the you know year
plus follow-up data and so the
authorization allowed the vaccines to be
used um well the clinical trials were
collecting the longer term you know
clinical trial data so so these were
clinical trials that went on for at
least a couple of years um and so they
had data you know initial data on safety
and efficacy um over months that they
had accumulated but not years and I so I
think my understanding is that's one of
differences representative
mcarter thank you madam chair just as a
followup to my previous question are you
are you able to point specifically to
any studies that have been done that uh
um that supports the recommendation
continuing today to vaccinate children
what what is your department or you in
your professional resume you you clearly
know more about this sort of stuff than
I um what studies can you specifically
point to that supports making the
recommendation to the public in New
Hampshire to vaccinate children against
covid-19 yeah so the the process and the
data that I outlined before is still
relevant
um the um you know so I would point you
first to the use of these vaccines and
the study of these vaccines over the
last four four years um the data has
accumulated uh it's been presented
publicly I would point you to the the
science brief that we put out uh with
some of that data um you know I will
also point out that you know 19 was
causing in children uh multi-stem
inflammatory
syndromes misc multistem inflammatory
syndrome and children children were
being hospitalized there there's data
continuing to this day showing that um
co9 contributes to um a higher risk of
diabetes in kids for for whatever reason
um you know this is specific to Children
uh so there are consequences of covid-19
still in all age groups including in
children with that said um the severity
of the disease has lessened um the focus
for vaccination um and the highest
priority for vaccination is on people
that are higher risk uh older adults
people with compromised immune systems
which includes children uh people with
multiple medical problems which also
includes children um so there is still a
role for um having vaccine available uh
for all age groups uh and the the data
and the review of the data for example
you know through FDA and acip supports
that the benefits outweigh risks of
vaccination in in all the age groups for
which the vaccine is recommended but
again at the end of the day this is an
individual decision so the the vaccine
is is available the recommendations are
out there um parents can choose whether
or not to get their child vaccinated um
the the groups that we are stressing the
importance of vaccination um are those
higher risk groups which can include
children
followup thank you madam chair so I I
understand the FDA and the other um
organization is making the
recommendation but can you particularly
cite a specific study that supports that
recommendation are you able yeah I point
you back to the science brief we put out
ago represent
poov thank you for taking my second
question uh follow up on what was just
discussed so uh you mention highrisk
groups that uh can uh include children
uh but um uh if we take um um otherwise
healthy kids uh is it possible that uh
your office uh uh can review your
decision uh from two years ago and
review the need of it and previously we
discussed with a representative Merchant
who recommended this committee to focus
on what was known and what decisions New
Hampshire uh takes based on what was
known and uh I see four facts first fact
from the early Wuhan data uh we saw that
unlike flu and other diseases covid
doesn't affect kids as much uh kids are
not
typically
uh affected population as much as
elderly people uh second uh uh if we
take New Hampshire data D dashboard uh
it shows uh uh minor deaths from covid
uh but uh uh according to CDC that
included uh multiple severe
comorbidities so uh for all those years
not a single otherwise healthy kid died
of covid according uh to CDC data and um
despite uh um early data showing 95 uh
efficient in preventing infection now we
know that vaccines do not stop
transmission so vaccinating healthy kids
won protect vulnerable populations from
infection and finally previously you
testified in state house uh that there
are some statistically significant side
effects known such as myocarditis and
young males from covid vaccine so given
those four facts uh I would suggest that
there's a time to review
recommendation uh for otherwise healthy
kids uh I I agree with you that if maybe
we should leave availability but but my
question about
recommendation thank you I'm sorry what
what's the can you clarify what the
question
is uh are you open in reviewing your
recommendation uh to vaccinate otherwise
healthy kids so so actually maybe this
is an important point we we are not um
creating our
own guidance around vaccination we
are pushing out and
messaging the federal science-based
acip represent P do you have followup
I'll also maybe I'm sorry to clarify
that people that have concerns or
questions about the vaccines need to
discuss it with their healthcare
provider right so you're absolutely
right that there is an association I've
said this before um that there's an
association between uh covid-19
vaccination and myocarditis in
particularly young males so um teenage
males and and young adults um it took
vaccination at a population level for
that rare outcome to be identified right
that's not something that could be
identified in the phase three clinical
trials even with you know tens of
thousands of people it took vaccinating
millions of people uh to identify that
that outcome and I point that out
because that's a rare and uncommon
Association but you're right it's still
a real and true um Association that has
been found over and over again with use
of the the covid-19 vaccines um that is
um people that have concerns about that
um should discuss that with their
healthcare provider for their specific
situation ation their specific health
status and ultimately at the end of the
day if a parent or Guardian um doesn't
want to vaccinate their child because
they're concerned about the side effects
then that's that's certainly their
choice there's no requirement out there
for for kids to be vaccinated um and the
the the federal recommendations the the
medical recommendations that are put out
by the ACP are what they are after
having gone through that scientific
review we're not we're not counter ing
or contradicting those Federal guidance
and we're not we're not putting out our
own different
recommendations uh because there's a
process and there's a medical group that
already reviews the science to to make
to make that
guidance uh representative groer then
representative beler thank you um I do
want to State though that I believe the
mission of this committee is to look at
how we handled the efficacy of not what
we're doing now I mean it's a completely
different
scope um but I do want to I would like
you to make a comment on the
atmosphere that the state was under the
country was under and the I think and
confirm right that everybody including
residents and and constituents of New
Hampshire and the state and the world
was trying to do the very best that they
can or that they they could with the
data that they had at the time that if
you could comment a little bit about
how um the evolution of a
situation
um tailors your response yeah that thank
you for that question because you're
absolutely right like what we're in now
is a normal steady state in terms of you
know reviewing the science doing the
data and putting out messaging around
sort of routine vaccine recommendations
whether that's the covid-19 vaccine or
you know pediatric pacle vaccine or the
new RSV vaccines right this is sort of
normal steady state work this was very
different from what was happening um
during the during the pandemic where um
we were probably reading and reviewing
almost every study that came out that's
a slight you know exaggeration probably
slight hyperbole but literally trying to
get our hands on you know every study
that came out um on new Therapeutics
that were coming out um to the earlier
question or vaccines um and messaging
that data um in real time to healthc
care providers
um the you know it it wasn't just
putting out recommendations and
information when the federal government
decided to put out guidance and and
recommendations
um that was often times delayed and so
we were in the situation of in real time
reviewing the science reviewing the data
um and proactively on a weekly basis you
know communicating with for example our
Healthcare Providers or Public Health
Partners schools long-term care
facilities about the the real active
data we we had um throughout the first
year of the pandemic we not only were
having the weekly press conferences we
were hosting weekly webinars for healthc
care providers along with weekly
webinars for schools along with weekly
webinars for long-term care facilities
so we were constantly sharing um updated
science and guidance on a weekly basis
for for months um with the these
different these various groups in
addition to the public messaging that
that I think people commonly saw so we
were in the this the uh proa acve state
of actively reviewing and putting out
information and messaging and sometimes
this led to us putting out different
guidance I'm I'm talking not the
vaccines um but you know putting out
different guidance uh very early in the
pandemic uh the federal government was
trying to roll out antigen testing to um
long-term care facilities to do more
testing so that they could prevent
outbreaks at long-term care facilities
now anybody that um was looking at the
data I shouldn't say anybody we were
looking at the data on those on what was
coming out with you know the the
accuracy of these antigen tests um and
thinking through the logistics of
implementing antigen testing at
long-term care facilities and we were
like you know we actually went to the
long-term care facilities and said we
even though the federal government was
saying use these use these antigen tests
we were saying don't use these antigen
tests for that purpose that's not what
they're primarily designed for and they
don't have the accuracy that you want
we're going to do something different
and set up a different better I think
you know better process for for rolling
out PCR testing uh in long-term care
facilities and so we we made that
resource available through you know
state government um and uh you know in
hindsight I think that was the the
better the better option so so we
weren't just blindly following what the
federal government was telling us doing
telling us to do and in fact a lot of
times the guidance wasn't there
um so we were in the setting of having
to develop our own
guidance but the vaccine guidance that
came out um was science-based and so the
vaccines first rolled out in December we
were reviewing the studies that were
coming out we were messaging those
studies we were sharing them uh the the
information and the data with Healthcare
Providers showing you know demonstrating
the the safety and the efficacy of of
these vaccines and that contributed to
the promotion and the roll out of
vaccines at a St state and local
level follow up you thank you madam
chair so and I'm listening to what
you're saying and in hindsight one of
the um points that I think we might walk
away with is
that um in a situation where we have a
pandemic there's a lot of messaging that
goes around correct and
so because we seem we have a Department
of Health and Human Services that is
that has the
expertise and has the ability to analyze
all this information that's coming into
them how do we although we can't I know
we can't limit the information that is
being received how is it that we could
give priority or at least
support the work that DHHS does for New
Hampshire is that something that you
could comment on because I think that
the work that you were
doing may have been lost in everything
else that was going on I mean I know
from a legislative standpoint we weren't
meeting either right we were all over
the place in New Hampshire looking for
some place to
meet um so which I felt I mean for me
personally I felt safe doing that
way but um you know I think some of the
work that you were doing especially in
for healthc care facilities and for
schools and for um the the data that you
were
getting was um is important and I don't
I wouldn't not that I want to ever put
our state or our country or our world
into that situation
again but um how do we communicate that
better uh communicate the public health
work and the yes that use that that New
Hampshire is specifically
doing yeah well thank you for that
question and I appreciate the um when
people ask about how to support public
health because um obviously I I maybe
biased I think Public Health work is
important um you know I think that
there's a couple different aspects that
you bring up one is um how to facilitate
Public Health work how to support Public
Health work the other is maybe more
around messaging how do we communicate
that to to people um so you know I think
that the the first question about
supporting Public Health work I I think
a lot of this goes back to sort of my
the initial question you asked and my
initial answer around you know
supporting the workforce the people
right I mean public health is a is a
person intensive Personnel resource
intensive uh work um and so you know
ensuring that we have the people but
also the systems uh to do that work
right there's there's a lot of people
involved and there's a lot of data
involved and I think both of these came
out during the pandemic of we need more
people and we need better Data Systems
and so these are these are conversations
and issues that are ongoing to this day
not just in New Hampshire but at a
national level lot lot of discussions
nationally about how to um how to
improve you know Data Systems and
improving the flow of data can improve a
response um the the second the second
Point uh is around communication and
that's that's maybe a more difficult um
a more difficult question to answer um
because I think everybody's struggling
with how do we better communicate with
people and I think the several
principles of communication that is that
you know how we communicate is going to
be very dependent
on excuse me the
audience um and the audience is going to
impact the type of message we put out
and how we deliver that message
right so whether we you know are are
communicating with people through the um
you know television or print media
versus social media right very different
audiences are using social media
compared to you know print media versus
the
television um you know I think I don't
have a great answer for that question
um we constantly struggle with
this not just with covid-19 but you know
any any dise disease
response we can be working at something
for months and months and then have
people out of the blue come up to us and
say hey are you doing anything with
ebola right this happened back in 2014
we spent months of our time like going
around doing presentations talking about
the West African Ebola outbreak and we
you know sending out message after
message to healthc care providers and we
we still had healthc care providers
months months into the response come up
to us and say are are what are you guys
doing with ebola like they people just
don't necessarily tune in and so it
becomes very difficult to make sure that
the message is getting consistently to
the to the right people and I think it
there needs to be better mechanisms and
better resources for communicating with
different Target audiences you know
right now in in the Department of Health
and Human Services we have a public
information office for example um that
has you know a staff for the I for the
entire department I don't know the exact
number it's like you know four or five
people people maybe um so you know
communication is is really important
because if the information and the
messaging isn't getting out there people
aren't knowing what's happening what
happened during the pandemic with the
weekly press conferences was that it was
such sort of a high-profile routine
recurrence that I think more and more
people were able to tune in but uh for
some of the the routine work that we do
the the you know sporadic outbreak
investigations or disease threats we
have it it continues to be a challenge
to get you know people's attention and
communicate
effectively uh Dr Chan I I really
appreciate you being here but I just
want to let the committee know that you
know we did receive some data that in
March of
2023 uh New Hampshire had the second
lowest cumulative covid-19 death rate of
any state um so uh we need to be
cognizant of our Public Health uh and
our governor for the good things that uh
happened during uh the covid pandemic um
but I do have a question for you and I'm
not sure if this
is with regards to mask mandates um I
don't know if your department had
anything to do with masking and my
question is um with the
virus um it's only so many
microns um so can you explain to me you
know when you
I guess it' be my first question yeah uh
so so I think there's actually a few
questions in there let me collect my
thoughts here for a second so um I I
think your ultimate question is about
how the virus is transmitted right does
it stay suspended in the air can spread
over longer distances versus it does it
spread more what we typically call
droplet format which requires close
contact with somebody infected or close
exposure um and that that has to do not
necessarily with the size of the virus
because all viruses are very very small
but um how long the virus can remain
viable suspended in air you know as you
have these little aerosolized particles
does the virus survive in those over
long distances or long periods of time
which can facilitate the the spread of
it you know through longer distances or
does it not survive over longer
distances does it require that close
that close personal contact to spread
um I I think there's a couple so there's
been there was a lot of focus over the
pandemic about how the virus spread
right and it's a respiratory virus so it
spreads through the respiratory route
the question is just whether it's
airborne and spreads long distances or
what we call droplet spreads through
closer contact like within 3 or six feet
um wait we didn't know you know early in
the pandemic because we didn't have that
information
um but some of the as the information
this is one of those areas where I think
the information changed over the
pandemic I think early on in the first
weeks and months
um the the evidence was pointing to this
primarily being spread through close
contact so you know within three or six
feet of you know being within three or
six feet of somebody that was infected
um and then over months and even years
there was other um as studies
accumulated there was other information
emerged that suggested that it could be
spread longer distances now certainly
with any respiratory virus the greatest
risk is people you know is people being
in closer proximity but I think there
was evidence emerging showing that it
could be spread over longer
distances um and so upfront in a
response
there um that that led to when you're
talking about mitigation measures that
that led to the recommendations around
you know avoiding close contact right or
being within six feet you know so the
physical distancing or the social
distancing to prevent somebody being
exposed to another person's larger
respiratory
droplets um that contributed to the
masking recommendations initially around
cloth face masks and then surgical face
masks and then you heard you know talk
about you know maybe people want to wear
n95 masks when they're out in public
which is a whole different debate um you
know but the idea being that you know
any masking of the face even with cloth
masks would prevent those larger
droplets from being spread you know
personto person and so certainly that
factored into some of the initial uh
recommendations the mitigation measures
around physical distancing and use of
face masks was to prevent that closer
contact droplet spread um there were
always uh the early on there were some
case reports
of um larger uh transmission events I'm
thinking there was a study that came out
early on about um a choir that was
singing and people got infected like a
large majority of the group got infected
even though they were not all within six
feet of the person that introduced it to
that group there were um reports for
example at a restaurant of somebody
infected and as air was blowing by like
a an air conditioner spread the virus
you know across a restaurant these were
individual sort of case reports coming
out and so I think we we realized I
think early on that in the right setting
or with in the right situation that the
virus could be spread longer distances
for example there's a fan blowing by
somebody or
um there are higher risk activities for
spreading the virus like if somebody's
infected and they're singing you know
the the vocal cords are going to you
know more likely aerosolize the virus
so I think that those kind of things
also factored into um guidance that
ultimately ended up coming out for
specific settings
um I I remember when guidance was being
developed you know there was separate
guidance um for golf courses and
equestrian facilities and guidance for
restaurants and hotels and you know
guidance for school sports and guidance
for activities like choir and band
practices and so those were the kind of
case reports and situations that we um
ultimately were trying to factor in like
are there higher risk settings where
this could spread further than you know
three or six feet um but to get to your
question and I'm sorry I'm rambling a
little bit here uh the to get to your
question about a mask mandate you know
Public
Health never in New Hampshire Public
Health to my recollection never mandated
masks right we helped to create
guidance um recommendations for how to
slow the spread and that and then that
guidance was put out and enforced
through other mechanisms right like we
don't have the legal authority to say
you're required to wear a mask right and
so that may have been part of the
guidance been been part of the
recommendations but the requirement for
that was through other larger State
mechanisms
thank you for that information I I
appreciate that and you're you're
absolutely correct uh that you can't
mandate it that was through the
government's executive orders um I guess
one of the questions I have um because
we're talking about public health and
the covid
pandemic and I
guess when it comes to the masking and I
understand we were using the Swiss
cheese approach um one of the things and
I don't know if this was recommended by
your department or not is in testimony
that we heard is one of the things that
I think should have been recommended um
by your department is air filtrations in
all schools um because I think that
would have really been a great
mitigation tool um and I'm not sure if
that's something uh you discussed or if
your department did um just out of
curios yeah no that's a great Point um
ventilation air filtration um increasing
the exchange of indoor air with pressure
outdoor air uh that certainly um
became uh so let me so
um early on there was certainly a
recognition and a recommendation around
you know open Windows you know and you
know outdoor events are safer than
indoor events right sort of gets at that
same issue of you know being outdoors or
having the windows open um increases
ventilation increases fresh air in
environment so that certainly factored
in you know early on I think to your
question about you know changing uh uh
schools ventilation
system um that that is um probably so
there was increased focus on that and
even money put towards that at a federal
level but that became more
prominent 2021
2022 but but that involved D not so much
Public Health as it involved I think
figuring out with the Department of
Education funding for schools to do this
um and then there's guidance that's put
out by an organization called ashray as
hre um which puts out uh guidance on
ventilation systems and
buildings um so there was a a technical
aspect to this as well that that wasn't
so much in public health course as it
was in some other organization but I
think early on there was certainly
recognition that increasing the flow of
fresh air was important but funding
schools to be able to update their
ventilation systems wasn't something
that came until later and that was money
that flowed I think from the I don't
want to speak on something I'm not
knowledgeable about but uh I think
flowed from the federal government um
and probably was directed more by the
Department of Education
right and I I I guess my question was is
not whether um who funded it or whatever
okay but um your department recognizing
that and maybe talking with the
commissioner of education and with the
governor and the task force for
reopening to uh especially where schools
were informed because um
even now every time someone goes back to
school there's outbreaks of colds flu
Etc because you're going back into these
closed buildings and Ill filtration from
a public health
standpoint would help mitigate at least
some of that even during the covid time
so I don't know if that's a
recommendation on your website just in
general um that okay it it it is and and
it's um that again that became more of a
focus and a recommendation later on uh
sort of the formal air filtration
ventilation
recommendations um and and you're right
it's
important I think it was increasingly
recognized throughout the pandemic as a
need um when we
realized the the deficiency of a lot of
buildings to have good air filtration
air handling units um but it wasn't
something that um could be responded to
in the immediate moment um for a variety
of reasons money you know people to go
in and change out ventilation systems in
a school or install a new ventilation
system but I think the pandemic
certainly highlighted that as a need for
prevention of any and all respiratory
viruses not just
covid-19 uh right so because you're a
policy department so that's why I was
just asking if that's uh one of your
policy
recommendations um the other question on
policy and because you're dealing with
public health
um I've seen you know I was on some
calls during the pandemic um and the
masking of children um we're now
learning uh has really hindered uh
speech development uh there's a need for
spee pathologist uh has has really
increased um because children not only
learn uh By Hearing but they learn by
facial expression and everything else um
and I've spoken with some teachers who
said that even after the fact when the
masks were no longer needed these people
were afraid to take off their mask
because they didn't who their they what
their identity was without it um and I'm
just wondering from your department when
we were talking about mask and you were
talking with the other groups and
letting them know that this was part of
going to be part of our swiss cheese
approach if you actually looked at uh
from a mental health standpoint um how
it was going to affect people especially
children yeah that's a that's a great
question and thank you for asking that
um let me
uh the other thing maybe that I should
have said up up front uh was
that a lot of what we did throughout the
pandemic was a balance right we're
always trying to find a balance between
preventing spread of covid-19 covid-19
mitigation and other aspects of Health
keeping kids in school I think we all
realized early on people that had kids
what
a not good situation it was to do remote
schooling for entire
schools um you know but so education
Financial Health you know people uh
being able to stay Physically Active
stay mentally healthy right there was
this Balancing Act throughout all the
pandemic of trying to balance covid-19
prevention mitigation with other aspects
of Health which is I think what you're
referring to in your
question um and so this is part of what
required to be changed over the months
and years of a pandemic response right
early on there was a real fear and um
uncertainty around covid-19 that
required maybe more of a focus on trying
to prevent covid-19 from spreading and
the unknown but potentially really
severe Health impacts we were hearing
about from China from Italy from New
York
City as we watched covid-19 spread and
learned more about it um particularly as
you know other resources became
available like some of the Therapeutics
like
vaccination that that balance shifted
from you know lessening the covid-19
mitigation recommendations and trying to
ensure that there was more focus on
people being able to go to work uh
staying active Outdoors you know making
sure that their you know impacts on you
know mental health um were were trying
to be addressed um and so I think the
your mask question is a pertinent one
because it reflects sort of that shift
um I don't think we knew what the impact
of you know masking children was was
going to be the the focus initially was
heavily on preventing the spread of
covid-19 but certainly we heard the same
reports that you expressed um over the
the first weeks and months you know
children having difficulty wearing masks
you know issues with you know reading
faces you know reading lips um emotional
Expressions you know speech pathologists
and there were some creative things that
people um came up with uh you know face
Shields instead of face masks for
example um but at the end of the day
this was one of those um areas where um
one there there were always uh
recommendations around you know if
people you know around um who shouldn't
wear a mask you know people that are not
recommended to wear a mask like for
example very young children it might not
be safe um but this is also one of those
areas where you know recognizing
that the masking of kids for example um
had consequences there was a need to
sort of try and shift that guidance over
time um and I can't remember exactly how
that guidance shifted and played out uh
we were we were helping to develop and
draft guidance on like a weekly basis
over years um but I think to your point
there was a recognition that you know
covid-19 mitigation measures can have
negative impacts I think we recognized
that early on um but it was always it
was always this Balancing Act between
trying to protect People's Health from
covid-19 and protect and promote
People's Health by being able
to engage in work and school and you
know physical activity
Etc I I appreciate that I I can't
imagine having to do that Balancing Act
um so thank you for that
representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and thank
you again um so my my picture of this
whole thing right now this whole
situation is kind of like a puzzle where
I'm missing pieces over here and a
little bit over here so I might if it's
okay and I'll ask for approval but to
jump around a little bit to try to fill
in my my total picture a little bit here
um so first and and you alluded to this
a little bit um when we talked about
vaccinations but uh as far as process
goes does the DHHS receive guidance or
orders from any federal agencies that
then become State policy messaging or
guidance and if so can you explain that
process and what if any direct input the
governor or executive Council has on
level um I'm thinking nothing jumps
there I'm sure there may be an example
out there well let me um so this isn't
necessarily state government um one of
the things we were dealing with during
the covid-19 pandemic um Medicare
Medicaid came out with requirements
of uh what's the term something uh
requirements for participation in
Medicare Medicaid right and so not not
the federal government but hospitals
that participated in Medicare were
required to
follow th that Federal guidance through
Medicare Medicaid as a requirement of
participation in Medicare that that's
one example but you know the the the
state has no control or no say in in in
any of that that's a a federal policy
through you know Medicare
Medicaid I just want to remind everyone
that the County nursing homes uh had to
deal with that a lot um and uh we were
very privy to what even H even having
subcontractors or contractors coming
into the facility what they were
required uh before they could even enter
uh if they were accepting those Medicare
Medicaid dollars so thank you for
bringing that out and that came up
around visitation in long-term care
facilities to to the point about mental
health a lot of um older adults were
suffering from isolation in long-term
care facilities um but we were somewhat
constrained by you know CMS guidance
requirements um that was controlling
some of some of this so if I may I I I
think I failed the the phrase my
question in the way that I had intended
it um I I what I'm getting at is are
there any sort of guidance or
regulations promulgated at the federal
level by by any individual or agency or
for that matter any any other level
including supernational for that matter
that then um is picked up by uh the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services to become guidance or anything
of that nature and you mentioned for
instance vaccination stuff was not
developed by New Hampshire DHHS that was
developed by a combination of private
sector and federal actors who was then
so that that answers it for that but as
far is there any other sort of stuff
that happens nothing nothing that comes
to mind nothing from like a legal or or
regulatory standpoint um that New
Hampshire is required to adopt I I mean
what what happens though is that what
happens at a federal level directly
impact like with Therapeutics like
vaccines or medications or
antivirals um what they're approved and
recommended
for I mean Healthcare Providers are
required not not by any state law or or
regulation necessarily to my knowledge
or at least Public Health regulation but
you know like at a federal level they're
approved for a certain indication and
providers need to follow you know
generally speaking use of those
medications under sort of the federal
guidance and regulation now there are
exceptions to that it's not like a black
and white issue because there's like off
Lael use of medications that that
sometimes happens but again that that
gets down to you know discretion at a
healthcare provider level for how to use
the resources available but nothing that
comes to mind that is like a requirement
put out or adopted by the state at least
from Public Health perspective okay
excellent thank you and if I may another
little bit of a different topic so as as
has been you know stated several times
it's very important that we look at not
just what we know now I mean in theory
hindsights 2020 but what we knew when we
knew it um So based on that we've
received a lot of testimony as a
committee from a lot of various sources
we've received a lot of documentation so
I have just just a couple questions
about whether or not the DHHS is aware
and I'll start here um is the DHHS New
Hampshire New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services aware um
regarding the controlled studies that
were done on the
vaccines that the control group in those
studies was vaccinated early over the
objections of the federal
FDA I I am not sure what you're
referring to we we reviewed the um
studies that came out and so I'm not
sure the what you're referencing where
where that information is the these were
the control trials um for I believe
fizer and madna um regarding their
vaccines that were released and this is
from uh testimony and documentation
received by attorney Aaron Siri uh this
is cooperated by um I believe it was
emails that this committee has um in our
possession um uh as far as there was a
request from the FDA that they not
vaccinate the control group in these
studies at a certain point in time and
despite that request they were
nonetheless immediately vaccinated right
after
that oh I I think so
um I think what you're referring to is
the
unblinding of the the different control
groups so right so so these clinical so
um I I I remember that being in the
media at some point I can't remember
when um so there are strict
processes that and again I don't I don't
uh I'm
not I'm not involved in these clinical
trials at all I'm just speaking for my
own knowledge about how clinical trials
are conducted um you know clinical
trials are conducted in in a specific
way and a specific process and monitored
by ethics boards and you know IRB these
internal review boards that you know
monitors to make sure that clinical
trials are being conducted in a ethical
fashion um and so what happens with um
these phase three clinical trials is you
know this this is in the terminology you
know double blinded Placebo control
clinical trials to prevent biases from
being introduced into a study you have
two different groups and and people
don't know whether they're getting the
control or the placebo and or versus the
you know investigational vaccine um and
that's there's a variety of reasons
behind that to helps you know increase
the validity and the scientific accuracy
of the results um but what happens is
that you know there's a group that
routinely monitors the results and at
some point if the vaccine is being found
in their study population to be safe and
highly effective there's there can be an
unblinding um so people can figure out
which group they're in and the people
that got the placebo or the fake you
know saline injection for example can
then be offered the real vaccine and I
think that's what you're referring to um
and I don't I'm wasn't involved in any
of those you know Federal discussions
this is all this is all managed through
um this is all managed through you know
ethics and advisory boards and whatnot
um but when the vaccine had been shown
to I I presume to be 95% effective there
was probably an an unblinding it's my
guess uh and the vaccine was then
offered to the control group so that
they could then be protected ected in
the midst of the pandemic I do remember
that that was an issue that came up um
and I'm not sure what uh what you're
were referencing about the FDA
recommending that that not happen I
vaguely remember some I I'm I can't
comment on that because I I'm not
familiar enough with what was said or
the context that that was said in but
just putting out there that there's a
whole like process an ethical review to
make sure that these studies are
conducted in a safe and ethical manner
excellent thank you and may I
represent po off uh thank you uh follow
up a question on your Authority in
regards to acip
recommendations uh so uh if I understood
uh you agree with guidance to uh
vaccinate otherwise healthy kids and
your assessment is that it's
science-based but generally like some
countries do not recommend covid
vaccines for otherwise healthy kids and
nationally uh since Jan
24 Florida called for hold in the use of
covid-19 mRNA vaccines and Florida does
not recommend boosters for 24 25 yeah
yeah yeah uh so um do you have authority
to override acip recommendation if you
ever see that it's con what science
shows
us I I'm not sure what you mean by
override acip recommendations I mean
those are the National medical
guidelines we have
control general surgeon have authority
to not recommend uh covid-19
vaccines do I understand correctly that
you you have the same Authority if you
ever see that it's counterproductive we
could put out whatever recommendation we
wanted um but our recommendations would
need to be based on the science and the
evidence which we've already discussed
um and you know have and uh I would
suggest that what Florida put out is is
not science or evidence-based you know
guidance and and representative PS off
just um just want to make sure that you
know because we're doing we're looking
at what happened during covid and I
understand we want to see what's
happening now versus what happening then
but um we need to uh look at that we
still
have I understand thank you represent
weary
sorry uh thank you mam chair and uh
thank you Dr Chan for taking this
question um
so I have
um a scenario early on in your test mode
you mentioned testing and we know that
the
CDC in its initial tests that were
released uh later reported um that there
was a
30% uh failure rate of those uh in terms
of false
positives
and were you and this was you know
widely reported
in I believe 2022 or was when the HHS
report came out and and
so did when did New Hampshire become
aware of this kind of problem and how
how did that affect
you know your decision-making process
once you became aware of that uh kind of
issue with the covid test wait can you
clarify your question representative the
co testing is this are you referring to
the antigen tests you're referring to
the PCR based
tests the um I so I
believe so what which one was the
initial test
was was it well so so there
um May maybe I'll just speak generally
to
testing um PCR detects the actual
genetic material of the virus it's a
very very sensitive test um has a higher
what we call sensitivity meaning it has
a higher ability to detect infection
particularly lower levels of infection
infection earlier on um the the downside
of the PCR test that we that we realized
as as we were testing people uh was that
they can even after they were no longer
likely infectious meaning no longer able
to spread it to other people that people
could keep testing positive because of
how sensitive the test
was um for like sometimes days and weeks
after they were
infected um so that that became an an
issue because early on there was a
recommendation that people were
infected which talking like very
beginning of 2020 people that were
infected could be let off isolation once
they tested negative by PCR tests and so
we had examples even in New Hampshire
where we were testing people for like a
couple of weeks more than two weeks and
they were still testing positive and
then we realized oh they're like they're
totally asymptomatic all their symptoms
are gone like they're still testing
positive like this isn't a reasonable
approach to using for using PCR testing
and so the
the that quickly switched from you know
get off isolation by testing negative to
more of a Time based you know after one
to two weeks for example you know after
being ill you don't have to stay at home
anymore we don't think you're still
likely to spread it to other
people um I think the larger issue
around testing was around antigen tests
right those are um tests that detect not
the genetic material of the virus but um
antigens or particles on the outside of
the of the virus those um very early on
even when they first rolled out in April
or May of
2020 um the data that was emerging show
was showing that there were problems
with false positives and false negatives
right false negatives because they
weren't sensitive enough to detect
infection early um more concerningly
though there was a certain there was a
high false positive rate and so this was
another area of the the literature that
we were continually monitoring of like
looking at the different tests that were
done and realizing that um some of these
had like a high false positive and false
negative rate and that's partly why when
the federal government ruled these out
to use in long-term care facilities we
said no don't use the antigen tests
we're going to set up a PCR testing
program instead um which is what we did
but that that was a problem with antigen
tests and that was recognized early on
um even you know April May certainly by
June 2020 um the data was emerging that
there were there were problems with
using an tests for screening
asymptomatic people right that's that's
how they were being promoted so the
other aspect of this was using these
tests for testing people that were
symptomatic versus te you know screening
people that were asymptomatic to see if
they were infected um and so both both
of these were needed to be factored into
how they were used and antigen tests
just had a lot of problems with using
them for screening now later on in the
pandemic um as they became more widely
available over the counter
there there was um and you know as PCR
testing became more you know it was more
expensive that's the downside of PCR
testing there um there was more of a
shift to allowing use of antigen tests
for um screening if somebody was exposed
but that was with the caveat that it
required multiple tests uh so I think it
was like 2022 maybe when the FDA finally
came out and said that if you're using
antigen tests for asymptomatic screening
you need a series of like three tests
over several days to you know be
confident that that if it's negative it
truly is negative um and that that was
the kind of data that was you know was
not new data uh that data had was
emerging throughout 2020 um and factored
into our recommendation early on not to
use antigen tests for asymptomatic
screening uh followup yes thank you um
so so taking stepping back from that uh
which I think is a great example you
know you have you're dealing with known
and unknown data you're dealing with in
some
situations um you know bad science you
know there's a poor design or a poor
understanding like like you mentioned
with the antigen for asymptomatic uh
screening um there's poorly executed
studies or insufficient data collection
how do
you how do you discern that process
you know or in that in that process of
reviewing all this literature how do you
discern when you have this bad sort of
science emerge how do you do you choose
to make that known or do you choose
to uh just point people in the direction
of what you think is good or do you does
part of the communication especially to
like Health Care Providers or hey we
we've had this situation where we're
feeling like we're not getting good
because of this situation you know is
that being shared with Healthcare
Providers is it you know so yeah and so
that's a great question and um the short
answer during the pandemic response
right when
we're reviewing articles on a daily
basis um was yes we sh we shared it with
Healthcare Providers we put it out in
health alert Network messages we sent
out our Han messaging system we were
sharing you know actual data and even
pre-print public ations with Healthcare
Providers on weekly webinars we were
having um you know and a lot of that was
to explain like why are we taking a
different approach from the federal
government when it comes to testing um
you know why why is New Hampshire saying
that people that are vaccinated who are
exposed to covid-19 no longer need to
quarantine but the federal government is
still telling people they should
quarantine even if they've been
vaccinated right these are all examples
of um times where we've diverged from
federal guidance based on the evidence
we had available you know at at the time
and so you know extrapolating this to
issues of you know vaccination you know
when when associations are made between
the um Jan the Jansen or Janson vaccine
and TTS
the thrombosis thrombocytopenic uh
syndrome you know that's message to
healthcare providers when there's an
association between you know covid-19
vaccines and myocarditis that that's
messaged to healthcare providers not not
that we're in our own messaging that you
know that gets put out at at a federal
level too like you know the vaccine
information sheets for example the
package inserts you know all all contain
the data out there that decisions are
based on for medical recommendations and
the um possible side effects from use of
the vaccine so it's not like that that
information is being hidden or not being
put out there but we certainly take
steps to make that information available
but it's already available at a federal
level put out through you know package
inserts vaccine information statements
and fact sheets put out by the federal
government which are available for
healthcare providers to use that are
vaccinating
people one
more thank you
um on a different tact
um we know that uh different country
well we talked about or you you
mentioned specifically uh different
states and different countries take
Taking different tax and approaches for
this and and we know for example Israel
was fully vaccinated Sweden was barely
or rarely
vaccinated were
you was the DHHS also evaluating kind of
those situations or you know do you have
the resources to to look at not just um
you know the differences between what
states are doing domestically but also
what different countries are doing
so I think there's two aspects of your
question one is um policies that
other places are making or
recommendations um and and certainly for
example we were aware during the
pandemic of what Sweden was doing
because it was in the news um the other
aspect is science put out um there was
there were a lot of studies coming out
of um the Israeli
population I believe I heard partly
because because fizer had an agreement
with the government to make vaccine
available and hence studied in their
population and and that promoted you
know scientific studies being published
um on use in that population which
certainly we reviewed so that was part
of what we were reviewing but it wasn't
just studies coming out of you know use
of the fiser vaccine for example in the
Israeli population we were also getting
studies from all other countries that
were publishing them so that that's part
part of like the scientific process of
you know studying and putting out you
know scientific studies and that's
that's primarily what we focus on not um
not necessarily comparison of you know
what Sweden is doing or what another
country is doing with their
recommendation but more on what is the
science that's emerging whether it's
science from Sweden or science from you
know Israel or science from the US or
science from you know the UK um it it's
just a a fact that some of these other
countries have systems better set up to
be able to conduct the science and so
you know Israel the UK were countries
that were putting out a lot of Science
and a lot of evidence and data that we
were reviewing you know during during
the
pandemic represent
Gro thank you madam chair um Dr Chan I'm
listening to the questions and I'm
listening to your answers and I'm
thinking
that the this
committee is trying to I think be
helpful
to Granite
that what the actions that we
took as a result of the covid pandemic
may not be
translatable to another
pandemic or what have we what's the is
there a Continuum or things that we
do you see what I'm trying to get to
like what is it that we can say as a
result of this of the things that we've
heard are helpful can be used again or
not helpful shouldn't be used again I
don't think we can make any of those
recommendations because I do I my
thought is after listening to you is
that what we learn from what we've
translatable so I think I think there
are things that so thank you for that
question that's actually a um I think
really important and relevant question I
think there are things that are
translatable um but there are going to
always be differences in the specifics
and the details right
um
so what you're getting at is an issue of
emergency preparedness and response
that's the sort of the the category I
would lump it it in preparedness and
response or public health preparedness
and
response
um
and I I think there's a few sort of
takeaways and I'm sorry as I I'm pausing
because because I'm thinking
um the first relative to the
conversation about Therapeutics and
vaccines yeah if I could
interject if there's other things that
you think about please let chair come to
I know and she can disseminate because
this is I think a come you know could be
a complicated
question it's a long-term question yes
um so I think there are so relative to
the conversation about sort of
Therapeutics and vaccines there
are federal scientific processes already
established by which things like
Therapeutics get reviewed and approved
by the FDA and then recommended by a
medical group of professionals that
review the science right in normal
peacetime if you will we we rely heavily
on that typical process um you know and
we have access to the data and the
science ourselves as well during a
pandemic we engage in more intensive
review of the science behind that for
the purposes of understanding the
recommendations being able to craft
messaging um and if we need to like we
did during the pandemic you know if
we're setting up statun vaccination
sites um we're responsible for the
messaging that's done to patients to
providers who are delivering
vaccine um and so there's a higher
greater need um and importance to
understanding a lot of the Nuance of the
science during a pandemic right and so
there are processes there that are set
up routinely at Baseline that we then
have to engage in more um intensively
during something like a pandemic that's
relative to the to the to the
Therapeutics but I'll just say relative
to the response as a whole um a lot of a
lot of our ability to respond
effectively I think comes down to some
general principles which have already
been highlighted one is an issue of
Workforce having the people to do the
work the other that I I I haven't
mentioned yet um and am remiss because I
should have is Partnerships right we we
can't do Public Health work without the
Partnerships of a great number of other
people um
both inter a intra agency so ton of
people were involved in the covid
response within the Department of Health
Human
Services then you had probably every
other department in state government
involved in the response in some way um
and we had to engage our Health Care
system and our Healthcare Providers and
our schools and our businesses and you
know I remember even having
conversations with you know faith-based
organizations so like it it really is an
an issue of if building those
Partnerships ahead of time will better
allow us or allow us to be in a better
position to respond to an emergency you
know if and if and when it's needed so
that comes down to Partnerships but also
somewhat the the the having the systems
established to be able to you know when
there's an empo outbreak and we need to
roll out an empo vaccine to make sure
that the systems are in place to be able
to do that efficiently um just as an
example um and then the other aspect
that I think you highlighted earlier was
around communication um communication is
critical and it depends on um not just
Public Communication communication with
Healthcare Providers communication with
um you know maybe subpopulations that
are impacted by a disease um
so I I I think that there are things
that can be done during peace time if
you will to um have a you know to to
have those systems and Partnerships in
place to have those communication
mechanisms you know set up and and again
a lot of this was highlighted I think in
the after Action Report um by H HSM
around you know the Partnerships and you
know the training and the practicing and
um making sure that people are aware of
their role during uh um during a
response um the most of what we deal
with in public health does not rise to
the level of a global pandemic like
covid-19 and so the scale of the
response hopefully is once every you
know hundred year if that you know
response that required to do but you
know in any given year there's still a
variety of issues we have to respond to
I mean just over the summer we were
dealing with andox Resurgence and then a
measles outbreak and um uh you know Aven
influenza you know in dairy cattle and
people getting infected and now there's
marberg virus so you know I mean that's
I missing some there um but there's
always diseases and outbreaks and not
just infectious diseases that we're
responding to you know toxicology issues
people Expo being exposed to you know
opioids as an ongoing issue there was a
anyways I won't belabor the point but
you know that the more that we can build
up these Partnerships and and practice
and train together the better response
will
be um yeah I remember and thank you for
bringing that up but I do remember
during the pandemic a lot of businesses
flipping over what they were doing uh to
help like hand sanitizer and things like
that um and really came together to help
uh for the public health um and worked
with the state
agencies um so uh representative beler I
I just want to say I do have a hard stop
at 11 I have another meeting that I have
to transition to at 11 thank you madam
chair I'll try to get through this
quickly then um so just to rewind a
little bit we talked about the
difference droplet versus Airborne at
what point was it apparent to Public
Health authorities that this was in fact
virus um I I will say that it's a
spectrum like any any infection is on a
spectrum right so it's not a black and
white line of this virus is Airborne and
this virus is droplet often times
there's there's a spectrum of
infectiousness which is partly where you
get the r not from at that I think that
you referred to
um is is a reflection of how infectious
was that's that's a little bit of a
difficult question to answer because
there
were people people at a national level
and actually International level saying
this is Airborne this is Airborne um you
know it's coming out in the media long
before it was clear that it was you
know that it that there was a there
could could be a significant Airborne
component
um so we were we were operating under
the assumption that it was primarily
droplet for quite a while
um into sometime into 2021 and I think
over 2021 it became more and more
apparent that um there were increasing
examples of of Airborne spread
um and you know thankfully by then we
had a vaccine available and so masking
was becoming less and less of of an
issue at that point but you know there
was still I'm trying to think when when
the the federal government even came out
with guidance saying that people might
want to consider wearing n95 masks in
public um I think that was like 2022
maybe so you know there was a whole
spectrum of time where it it really
wasn't clear um but anytime there's
emergence of a new
pathogen the Baseline recommendation for
Health Care infection prevention is
wearing an n95 mask even if even if
there's not um clear evidence of airborn
transmission with any new emerging
infectious disease pathogen the Baseline
um uh the Baseline PPE if you will
personal protective equipment
recommended in the healthc care setting
are like n95 masks we we we saw that
with um Aven influenza for example
anybody that comes in with Aven
influenza um even though it hasn't been
shown you know the h5n1 virus uh even
though it hasn't been shown to be
transmitting person to person if
somebody's exposed dairy cattle comes
down with what they think is you know
h5n1 influenza EV and influenza
infection and they go into the
Healthcare System those Healthcare
Providers should be wearing n95 masks
not because it's Airborne but because
that's the sort of the standard
operating procedure for dealing with a
new infectious pathogen in the
healthcare setting but that doesn't
translate into the public setting until
you know the evidence accumulated over a
year or two thank you uh may I follow up
um so uh you've mentioned that initial
uh clinical trial data for the vaccine
suggested a 95% rate of efficacy for
preventing the contraction of uh of the
virus has our understanding has DHHS
understanding of that changed over time
and if so when when when approximately
did our understanding
evolve so
um the again the initial clinical trial
data showed 95% Effectiveness for the
MRNA vaccines at preventing infection
as the virus evolved over
time so over months it
became clear that that protection didn't
last meaning immunity waned or
decreased um and there were a couple
reasons for that one is just the passage
of time so somebody's antibody levels
decreasing over time the others that the
virus evolved very quickly in fact um to
different variants
and so the combination of those two
things
um the LED to studies
emerging
um I would
say but by the middle by the middle to
end of
2021 it was becoming more clear that
protection was not lasting either
because of time or because the emerging
of variance um
and so that's when I'm trying to I'm
pausing as I'm trying to think back
TimeWise that's when we had the Delta
variant emerging and then the year after
that we had Omron so it was probably
around emergence as these new variants
emerged over the summer and into the
fall and the winter you had the beta
variant then you had the Delta variant
um and so it became clear that the
vaccine immunity wasn't lasting and and
initially we thought that that was due
to the rapid change the rapid change in
the virus and the mutations of the virus
um that allowed the antibodies
protection not to work as well but I
think it became apparent that it was
also just duration from vaccination that
led to a decline in immunity as people
studied like the antibody response and
saw waning antibody response over time
but that that was data that emerged
through
20122 last one sure actually well
this is uh this is me rubbing the lamp
getting the genie Third Wish asking for
more wishes but um I want to ask because
there are a lot more questions not
terribly complicated ones but we just
don't have time to get to all of them
right now would it be possible to
forward to you so either you or your
staff could provide us just you know in
writing or verbally answers to a number
of other fairly simple questions along
the same lines as we've been asking so
far I I mean sure I don't you're I I
think you have aby's contact information
getting yeah that would be great thank
you uh does anyone else no well Dr Chan
I know that you are pressed for time and
um I just want to thank you so much for
being here it's really important for us
to understand what we got right what we
got wrong we know that every pandemic is
going to be different
um no two things are ever the same so
but if we can learn anything from this
pandemic uh what we got right what we
got wrong um that is really what the
goal is so that the next time this
happens is we have something we can look
at um so I appreciate uh you being here
and uh helping us through this my
pleasure thank you thank you for your
time and your attention I appreciate it
afternoon anybody after not right now no
you're we're
it thank
you uh would everyone like to take a uh
10 minute
recess okay so we'll be back here at
11:05 no
1110 no right
I'm looking at two different clocks on
resume just
gon
we
e
time being 11:10 I'm going to pull this
out of recess um so uh Dr Chan just
testified in front of our committee for
2 hours if anyone has any more questions
that they would like to submit to him
please email me and I will forward that
on to Abby his uh the legislative liais
on um and we will try and get those
answered uh in a timely manner so
um yeah if you could probably get them
done today uh that way we could get them
in time for next week's meeting if we
need to go over
anything okay anyone want to have a
discussion about the testimony we just
heard
uh representative
beler thank you madam chair I just want
to say um I think that was that was very
useful the only thing I would have
wished for is a bit more time because
there's so many more sort of detailed
easy you know easy yes or no or timeline
questions to kind of resolve to help
really get the picture um
but I think that was very useful on the
whole um we do have a report that will
um assume I'm should be done uh for
November
1st um
and
uh you know we need to really focus on
the
positives um and also what we can
improve on uh that happened during the
pandemic um and again some of the
takeaways
uh that we have heard in front of this
committee over time is um you know how
do we eliminate uh so much fear in a
pandemic um because uh not only does and
a lot of that came from the federal
government and how can the
state um
counter act I guess
uh step in and and help eliminate that
um
because it doesn't help anyone's uh it
it actually has an adverse Health effect
on people
um when they're afraid to do anything uh
so um I'd like to make sure we have a
section on that uh in the
report um you know we heard from
commissioner edelblute how he tried to
stay positive and say you know we can
get through this you know we've done
this before
you know the country's been through
things you know let's stick together
move forward um you know trying to get
out that positive messaging and I think
um although it was a very scary time for
everyone here in the state um and the
unknown you know it's always you're
always fearful of the
unknown but how do
we keep everyone moving forward in and
and in a positive light um we've learned
a lot about uh uh the schools you know
the air filtration the ventilation um I
think uh and you know in in hearing our
testimony and learning about the school
in New York that never shut down because
uh they were nervous because of it was
an children with autism uh what kind of
damage that would do and how they uh
hired an industrial hygienist uh and he
went in and out fited that
school um and there were no outbreaks of
covid um in that school so you know
there's things to be learned there's
things that I think even in an upcoming
pandemic that if we start implementing
and make sure they're done properly now
uh can help mitigate some of the
solutions and we also have to understand
that no Pand to pandemics are the same
every virus is different and will react
differently um and they will attack
different populations we know that Co
really went after the elderly we had a
um it really you know the nursing home
population was devastated in our state
um but we I think we also learned that
leaving people alone and uh isolating
them is not also a good policy and how
do we mitigate that going forward and
what precautions can we take so that
people aren't alone
um when they're when they're you know
when they're dying and their loved ones
can't get to see them um you know
because these have uh long lasting
mental health effects so and I think Dr
Chan got it right you know it's a
balancing act we're we're in a pandemic
we're trying to you're trying to deal
with public health policy but you're
also trying to look at everything else
and you know New Hampshire did take a a
good did pretty well I in The Balancing
Act and I think through some of Our
Testimony we learned uh we did a lot of
things right but I think there's some
things we can do different uh going
forward and Dr Chan touched upon it
messaging is big and I think that's
something that we really need to stress
in our report is how messaging is done
so does anyone else have anything they'd
say representative
Gro thank you I think one of the the
components that he talked about were
communication health care workers the
supporting that
community and um I think those are the
two things that he said we could so if
um in our work as legislators we look at
ways to promote Health Care as a
profession because there are many
different levels of health care right
you don't have
to necessarily be a physician you can be
a nurse you can be an LNA you can be an
LPN I mean there's many professions and
I know that um it's an area that I've
been focusing on and I will continue to
focus on because I think that um there's
a lot of emphasis on the trades right
now which is important but but nursing
is a trade
too representa grer I absolutely agree
with you and when we think about health
care we're not we're not just thinking
about uh lnas or RNs it's a whole
administrative
uh Staffing so it's it's not just one um
but you know we did pull in uh we had
our National Guard uh that we pulled in
to help with this also uh as a resource
um you know so we we we have resources
we can pull on um but we also lost a lot
of healthcare workers due to mandates so
we have to recognize again there's The
Balancing Act
um that has to go
on
so if uh no one else has anything they
would like to discuss uh our next
meeting will be
October 25th at 10:00
a.m.
um we may have a guest speaker if not um
I would really like to uh focus on the
report um and
uh looking at the guidelines uh the
outline and uh what's what's been what
we has been written uh go through it
let's critique it tweak it how we need
to um so that on November 1st at 10:
a.m. uh we can take a look at that final
report um so uh without further
Ado um we will adjourn at 11:17 uh
everyone have a great weekend thank you